اضعفنا الاقتصاد الروسي
فتاه بوتين الحديديه وصاحبه نظريه النفط
مقابل الروبل الروسي نعم لقد اعلنتها
السفاحه الاقتصاد الروسي قائله فلتبتعد
قبل ان نهدمها فوق رؤوسكم ونجردكم من
قبعاتكم الطويله لتعلنوا افلاسكم ضباع
واشنطن ترد سنقاتل حتى اخر نفس وما بنيناه
في 80 عاما لن يسقط بسهوله اصحاب العيون
الضيقه يتناولون الاندومي الساخنه هيا
لنضع حدا للدولار ولنجرب امريكا من صيادها
الذي اوجع اقتصاد العالم كيف احتلت امريكا
على العالم وباعت له الهواء لتفرض اوراقها
الخضراء على العالم هي كانت خطه صدام حسين
سابقا وكانت هي السبب القوي الذي دفع
امريكا الاحتلال العراق اليوم الصين
وروسيا تنفضان الغبار من هذه الخطه لتعود
الى الواجهه مجددا فهل ستنجح اليد الروسيه
الى جانب اليد الصيني واضف عليها اليد
السعوديه في سحب سيات الدولار من الايادي
الامريكيه عن مذبحه الدولار الامريكي
نتحدث وللقصه بقيه
الذهب مقابل قصاصه ورق قد تظن ان الدولار
قد تسيد العمله بسبب قوته ولكنك مخطئ يا
عزيزي فالامر في حقيقته لم يكن سوى عمليه
احتيال خبيثه من ابناء العم سام على
العالم كله ففي نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وتحديدا في يوليو عام
1944 عندما ايقن الحلفاء ان انتصارهم في
الحرب قامت الولايات المتحده بالطرق على
الحديد وهو ساخن لكي تضمن وضع مقدرات
العالم كله في قبضه يدها في منتجع بغابات
بريتن وودز بولايه نيو هامشير الامريكيه
انعقد مؤتمر النقد الدولي او فيما يعرف
بمؤتمر بريتنوت
ممثلون لاربع واربعين دوله هم الاقوى في
العالم اشهرهم الاتحاد السوفيتي والصين
وبريطانيا وفرنسا وامريكا بالطبع اتفق
المجتمعون على استبدال قاعده الذهب
بالدولار الامريكي اي اعتماد الدولار
كعمله دوليه تقوم الدول بتسليم الذهب الذي
لديها لامريكا وتاخذ بدلا منه قصاصات من
ورق الدولار تساوي قيمته وفي حال ارادت اي
دوله استرداد الذهب الخاص بها فان امريكا
تلتزم برده لها شرطت ان تدفع هذه الدوله
قيمه الذهب من الدولار مره اخرى وتم تحديد
سعر اونصه الذهب بخمسه وثلاثين دولار لا
عجب ان توافق دول عظمى مثل بريطانيا
وفرنسا على تلك الاتفاقات المهينه فالدوله
الثاني كانت في حاله انهيار اقتصادي بسبب
الحرب العالميه بالاضافه لديونهما الضخمه
التي كانت لصالح امريكا المستفيد الوحيد
من الحرب في ذلك الوقت والتي استطاعت
استغلالها احسن استغلال على ايه حال انتهى
الاجتماع وتم الاتفاق وصارت الامور كما
خطط لها الضبع الامريكي ارسلت دولا عديده
كميات ضخمه من الذهب الى واشنطن واخذت
بدلا منها الدولار ظن العالم انه على
اعقاب اصلاح اقتصادي يعوضه ما نزفه بسبب
الحرب بينما كان الجميع على موعد مع اكبر
عمليه احتيال دوليه حدثت في التاريخ
العالم يقع في الفخ الاخطر
جاءت اواخر الستينيات ليذهب الرئيس
الفرنسي شارلي جول الى واشنطن حاملا حقيبه
ضخمه مملوءه بالدولارات قائلا اريد ان
استرد كميه من الذهب الخاص بفرنسا كما
اتفقنا وها هي قيمته من الدولارات مطله
الحكومه الامريكيه في تنفيذ طلب مرت اشهر
كثيره ولم يظهر الذهب فرنسا الشك يدخل في
قلوب دول اوروبا ليطالب واشنطن بالذهب
الخاص بهم كما وعدتهم ولكن جاءت الصفعه
القويه على وجه الجميع ليظهر في عام 71
الرئيس الامريكي
على شاشات التلفاز معلنا عدم قدره واشنطن
على الايفاء بوعدها ورد الذهب الذي اخذته
من الدول وانه ليس امام الدول التي وثقت
في وعود واشنطن الا ان تعتمد على الدولار
الامريكي كعمله رئيسيه في اقتصادها دون
ربطها بالذهب ماذا تقول يا نيكسون كيف حدث
هذا ليرد دانيكسون معذره يا اصدقاء فقد
اضطرد من الدولارات خارج غطاء الذهب من
اجل الصرف على حرب فيتنام وكان لسان حال
واشنطن يقول لقد وثقتم في امريكا وسلمتم
لها ذقنكم لذا كان عليكم ان تدفعوا الثمن
والى لقاء اخر في عمليه احتيال اخرى لتصبح
هذه اكبر عمليه احتيال في التاريخ منذ ذلك
الحين ودول العالم تتخبط والاقتصاد
الامريكي يعلو اكثر فاكثر واصبح الدولار
سياطه واشنطن تضرب به ظهر اي دوله تعاديها
ولن نذهب بعيدا كايران مثلا والتي اصبحت
عملتها لا تساوي سعر الحبر الذي تم وضعه
عليها وغير ايران الكثير ممن طال هم سياط
الدولار الامريكي المؤلم فاذا اردت ان
تبني اقتصادا قويا يجب ان تنال رضا امريكا
اولا وان قلت له ستصحو على البلاطه كما
يقولها المصريون ولكن يبدو ان هناك دوله
قالت له لا لا ليست دوله بل دولت وفي
وقتنا الحاضر نعم هما روسيا والصين وان
اتت كلمه لا متاخره فهي خير من ان لا تصل
ابدا ويكفي انها اتت فما الذي حدث
اغتيال الدولار
اشتعلت الحروب وسحبت واشنطن سياتها لتعاقب
الفاعل فمن هذا الذي تجرا ليقف بوتين يقول
انا هنا ومن خلفه صديقه المقرب
فبعد غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا قامت امريكا
بتجيش المجتمع الدولي ضد بوتين واستغلت
اهميه الدولار في توقيع عقوباتها
الاقتصاديه على روسيا ظنت واشنطن ان فرائس
موسكو سترتعد ولم تكن تعلم ان لكل فعل رده
فعل كما تقولها قوانين الفيزياء الممله
العقوبات الامريكيه وحليفتها من الغرب
تستبيح جسد روسيا الاقتصادي ليسقط الروبل
الروسي صريعا يلفظ انفاسه الاخيره لتتدخل
هنا جراحه الاقتصاد
والتي انقذت اقتصاد روسيا سابقا من
العقوبات الامريكيه عندما التهم بوتين
جزيره القرم الاوكرانيه اليفيرا سنبيع
النفط مقابل الروبل الروسي نعم وماذا بعد
يا اليفيرا ايضا سنغلق اكثر من 276 بنكا
ومصرفا روسيا بتعاملها الحر مع امريكا
واوروبا بشكل مباشر لنؤمن الظهر الروسي
وهذا ما حدث ليعود الروبل الروسي بكامل
صحته وبعد ان تشاور الحلفاء لتنفيذ هاتريك
يهز شباك الاقتصاد الامريكي اعلنت روسيا
والصين تخليهما عن التعامل بالدولار
وانهما ستعتمدان في معاملتهم التجاريه على
اليوان الصيني والروبل الروسي وما ادراك
ما التعاملات التجاريه مع الصين تنين
عملاق خسره الاخضر الامريكي فمنذ اتفاق
روسيا والصين تضاعف حجم التجاره بالروبل
اكثر من ثمانين ضعفا عن معدله الطبيعي
والامر ليس مرهقا للدب الروسي او الطنين
الصيني فمنذ عام 67 كانت البنوك المركزيه
الروسيه والصينيه تشتري الذهب باسرع وتيره
وبكميات ضخمه ليتكون عندها احتياطي عملاق
من المعدن الاصفر وهذا ما ساعد روسيا
والصين في ذبح الورقه الخضراء وبالسكين
بارد سقوط الذبيحه يقول المثل اذا سقطت
الذبحه كثرت سكاكين الجزارين وهذا ما حدث
مع الدولار بالضبط فالدب الروسي واصحاب
العيون الضيقه كانوا فقط من دق اول مسمار
في نعش هيمنه واشنطن اذا لم يكونوا
الاولين بل هناك رجل اخر قد سبقهم ففي حرب
العراق وحصارها اوقف صدام حسين التعامل
بالدولار واستخدم عمله اليورو كونها عمله
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولن تتجرا امريكا على
المساسبات ليلحقه بعد جمع غفير ممن يريدون
ان يتحرروا من صوت الدولار الامريكي وعلى
راسهم دول الاوروبيه حيث انضمت كل من
فرنسا والبرازيل والارجنتين والهند
والسعوديه وايران وافغانستان وغيرهم
الكثير الى قافله التحرر من عمله الدولار
الامريكي ففي العام الجاري سعرت فرنسا
والصين شحنه غاز اماراتيه بلغ حجمها 65
الف طن من الغاز الطبيعي باليوان الصيني
واعلنت السعوديه موافقتها على اتمام
معاملتها التجاريه الدوليه بعملات اخرى
غير الدولار وبدات الهند في تسديد مستحقات
روسيا من وارده النفط بالدرهم الاماراتي
وتعمل روسيا وايران على انشاء عمله مشفره
وربطها بالذهب لاتمام تعاملاتهم التجاريه
بها واتفقت البرازيل والهند مع الصيني على
ان تتم المعاملات التجاريه بينهم باليوان
ولا تستهن بالبرازيل يا عزيزي فهي صاحبه
اكبر اقتصاد في امريكا اللاتينيه وك يبلغ
قيمه معاملاتها التجاريه مع الصين فقط
اكثر من 150 مليار دولار امريكي سنويا
ويبدو ان خسائر الاخضر الامريكي في امريكا
اللاتينيه لم تقف عند هذا الحد فالبرازيل
والارجنتين تريدان انشاء عمله مشتركه
بينهما لاتمام معاملتهم التجاريه بعيدا عن
الدولار نذهب الى اسيا حيث في مؤتمر عقد
في سنغافوره يناير الماضي اعلن العديد من
مسؤول دول جنوب شرق اسيا رغبتهم في التخلي
عن الدولار الامريكي في معاملاتهم
التجاريه ولابد من ايجاد عمله اخرى بديله
وهنا ياتي السؤال الاكثر الحاحا على عقول
الاقتصاديين ما الذي ينتظر الدولار
مستقبل اسود ذهب بعض المحللين الى القول
بان ما يحدث الان لن يكون له تاثير في
الوقت الحالي على الورقه الخضراء فلا تزال
النسبه الكبرى من دول العالم تعتمد على
العمله الامريكيه في تعاملاتها التجاريه
ولكن هذا ما يبدو ظاهريا فقط فتمرد اكبر
اقتصادين في امريكا اللاتينيه وهما
البرازيل والارجنتين على الدولار يمثل
ضربه مؤلمه لوشنطن من جارتيها القاريتين
ناهيك عن خروج ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
وهو الصين من عباءه الدولار ودول جنوب شرق
اسيا التي تنوي توجيها نفس الضربه للعمله
الخضراء والهند لن يتنام حجم تجارتها
الدوليه يوما بعد يوم وحتى الان لم نتحدث
بعد عن خروج اكبر اقتصاديات في دول الخليج
كالسعوديه وانضمامها الى المعسكر الروسي
الصيني ولا اوروبا التي اعلنت فيها فرنسا
العصيان واتفقت مع الصين على امريكا ولا
تستغرب فالمصالح بتتصالح كما يقولها
المصريون صحيح لا يزال الدولار هو العمله
الرئيسيه في تجاره العدد الاكبر من دول
العالم ولكن العمله الخضراء فقدت اقوى
الاقتصادات التي كانت تعتمد عليها في
سيطرتها فالعدد الكبير هنا قد لا يساوي
شيئا لان واشنطن قد خسرت مركز الثقل واصبح
سقوط الدولار ليس سوى مساله وقت خصوصا وان
عدد الدول التي تخرج من عباءه العمله
الخضراء في ازدياد وربما نقول كلنا قريبا
بصوت واحد وداعا امريكا
[موسيقى]